[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
the
19th amendment
that is the amendment is why we are
where we are and that is why the
republicans are scared this morning
they're terrified
that this leaked
i'm talking about the supreme court
decision to overturn roe v wade and
strip away the liberty and the rights of
women
all over this country
don't think they won't come after the
19th amendment either
they're ready they're they're gonna
fight
they're gonna fight
yes it's a constitutional amendment and
some say oh tony tony they'll never take
that constitutional amendment away
they'll never take the the right of
women to vote away oh really
they won't huh they won't try to chip
away
at women's liberty
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
that's what you think
that they're not willing to chip away at
a woman's liberty in this country and
her rights
well good luck with that narrative from
here on out
i've been saying yelling and screaming
for months and months and months that
these fascists are coming for you
and it won't stop it won't stop
at women's right to the autonomy of
their body it will not stop there it
won't stop in the red states in the
cheeto dust confederacy it won't stop
there
they will not quit
they will not in the scourge of fascism
around this country to turn our entire
country not just the red states not just
where they have control
their goal
is for a fascist authoritarian
state
to tell you what you can and cannot do
with your body
to tell you what you can and cannot
consent for your body your children and
your family
they're ready folks
they picked a hill to die on that's
where they want to fight are we going to
stand down in the valley
and yell at
them to say come down here come down
here and fight us where we want to fight
no we march up on the hill and we fight
the battle that they want to fight they
want to take your [ __ ] liberty away
from you
now is the time now
is the time
to fight
so don't just tweet
get on your feet
march
protest yell
scream
be divisive that's right
tony don't say be divisive oh really
oh really you're just gonna you're just
gonna
you're just gonna let fascism take over
the
country because you're unwilling you're
unwilling to call fascism fascism
they're they're concerned about the leak
this morning oh my god can you imagine
who leaked this information
so early
that women in this country would
organize and march against us that's
what they're [ __ ] worried about folks
they're worried now more than
ever that the mobilization
a pro-democracy people in this country
has a head start
on the decision of the supreme court to
take away your
liberty
and all you men out there they're
listening to me thinking oh well what
the hell's this guy do with me hell i
can't have an abortion you think they're
not coming for you
they're ready to turn this into an
authoritarian fascist state they've been
ready for a long [ __ ] time
a long [ __ ] time
they've been ready to turn this into
authoritarian fascist state
it is very clear in this country
what we must do we must participate in
democracy five thousand percent
you know what scares these fascists more
than anything in the world
not guns not
threats democracy
terrifies them
the will of the people
frightens the holy [ __ ]
out of them
so let's use that weapon
let's use democracy let's show them
what we the people can do
when we exercise our right to our
democracy and our write to our liberty
and if you today are not standing up
just [ __ ] furious
that these [ __ ] [ __ ] boxes
that were bought and paid for for our
supreme court are stripping away our
citizens and our women in this country's
liberty you
are a piece of [ __ ]
garbage and you are not for democracy
i don't give a [ __ ] about pro-life and
pro-choice partial burst abortion i
don't give a [ __ ]
at this point
this is only about one fight and one
fight only
are you going to let them come and take
your rights
because they're coming
they're coming for the 19th amendment
you don't think that you think they're
just going to stand back and take
women's liberty and then let them vote
to secure it to codify it no they will
do anything in their power anything even
try to commit a coup
on our democracy
overturn our vote overthrow our
constitution
they're willing to do anything and
everything and they will take help from
anyone
including other authoritarians like
vladimir putin
and the scourge of disinformation and
misinformation and lies you lying
[ __ ]
and they've been doing it for decades
it ain't just now this lie about partial
burst abortion get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] that's all a [ __ ] lie
the lies that they spread on social
media of pictures of babies being killed
you're a [ __ ] liar
lies
and if you're pro-democracy out there if
you want to stand
for the vote for the people for women
for children all around this country and
to save lives now
is the time to get engaged
for our democracy
engage in the ballot
because they're coming for it
they're coming for the ballot your
ballot they're coming for it
mark my words doubt me
oh tony they'll never overturn roe v
wade you can't overturn roe v wade oh
well susan collins says oh well i'm
reassured that brett kavanaugh
and amy comey barrett and neil gorsuch
will not overturn roe v wade
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
you're gonna trust susan collins
if susan collins came out today and said
ah there's no way
there's no way that republicans that the
gqp that the fascist the nazi party that
they are
the despicable [ __ ] put nazis
there's no way they'll try to try to
bang up the woman's vote try to prevent
women and feminists everywhere from
voting bull [ __ ] [ __ ]
hide and watch
hide
and
watch
or
or
you can get on your feet
and you can go engage in the ballot
and enough of this [ __ ] it's his
fault it's her fault it's his fault and
it's shut the [ __ ] up
it's enough blaming ourselves
now is the time to not press blame now
is the time to fight who gives a [ __ ]
whose fault this is
who gives a good god damn who did what
and who said what and who when and who
where
get the [ __ ] out of here with that
[ __ ] more of that is gonna cause more of
fascism that's right you're you stand
around pointing fingers at whose fault
this is and you don't go up on that hill
and you fight for that ballot
you will lose you will [ __ ] lose and
everyone out there listening to my voice
continually says over and over and over
again democrats don't have a message
they never have a message they can't get
on message they can't find a message
they can't message worth a [ __ ]
it ain't up to the politicians folks
the pro-lifers the people that want to
strip away women's liberty the
anti-woman party
that is the gqp
they're organized folks
they're [ __ ] organized and they're
ready to whip your ass and take your
rights and make this a fascist state
they're ready
they're not just gonna stop at the
[ __ ] red states they're not just
gonna go oh well texas and florida and
kentucky you know missouri at there's no
abortion clinics there so now we're done
we're over we're good we're good to go
no
they're coming
they're coming for the blue states
they're going to do everything they can
to take away safe medical procedures for
women
because they [ __ ] hate women making
choices about their bodies
especially when it comes to
stockpiling their country full of
low-income workers
that's right
you think it man you think they give a
[ __ ] about life
you think they give two [ __ ] shits
about children these are the same
[ __ ] that are sexualizing your
children's gender with legislation
they're trying to marry children with
legislation in states
they were locking children up in cages
at the border you think they give a [ __ ]
about human life and children get the
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
now is the time
now
yesterday two weeks ago a month ago
they have awakened
a sleeping
giant
and my message to them
to the fascists in this country you
have no idea what the [ __ ] woke is you
sons of [ __ ]
you have no [ __ ] clue
i implore you fight fight fight fight
fight
democracy is worth every single little
inch
so go on that hill and fight for liberty
with the ballot use the ballot use
democracy against them
they fear it the most that's why that's
why you see
you see marsha blackburn this morning
we need to we didn't find who leaked
this they're all they're highly
concerned with who leaked it
they don't give a good god damn
about the liberty that is about to be
stripped away from human beings in our
country
don't give two [ __ ]
the freedom to oppress the rights
of other people
is not
liberty
it's in our intro folks
the freedom to oppress
the rights of other people
is
not
liberty
liberty is what we strive for in our
democracy it has been
for hundreds of years
is it perfect no democracy's not perfect
why should it be
should we strive for perfection
certainly
but not everyone is going to get what
they want out of a democracy
they're fighting
to oppress your rights
and we
us pro-democracy people
are fighting to preserve their liberty
and that's the greatest part about
democracy folks
that's the greatest part
is we get to die on the hill of liberty
where we defend not our right
to liberty
we defend everyone's right even their
right to liberty
that's what it's about
we've come a long way and we got a long
[ __ ] way to go
especially with these [ __ ] fascists
because they not only want to tear down
your liberty they want to tear down our
democracy they want to rip up and [ __ ]
on our constitution
they do not like democracy they have
decided that democracy affords everyone
they hate the liberty that they only
want to have
let me say it again
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people
is not
liberty
and if your goal no matter what no
matter what what system that you're
using in our government
rather it be the legislative system
inside states or the federal legislative
system
rather you're using executive orders
governors
the president of the united states
are you using our supreme court
to take away the rights of other people
that
is not
liberty
i don't give a [ __ ] who they are
who they want to be
what color their skin is how tall they
are how skinny they are how fat they are
i don't give two shits what religion
they are
what gender they identify as who they
love i don't give a [ __ ]
if they're willing to take their liberty
so haphazardly
they will come
for yours
that's what fascists do
and they're not going to stop
they're not going to stop here they're
going to oh
finally we overturn roe v wade
okay now we can
go back underneath our rocks
crawl back underneath them and hide away
they're not gonna stop at roe v wade
this whole state's right [ __ ]
they're gonna give you that argument
they're gonna sling that [ __ ] at you all
day long
over and over and over and over again
states right states rights
are the states rights more important
than human rights
to the state's rights
are they way more important than human
rights are they
maybe that's a good question to ask one
of these anti-woman
trump pumping
fools because that's the cheering that's
going on folks
that's the cheering
and democrats all around the the social
media network
that is our internet are playing right
into their hands
trump got us the supreme court picks
and what do liberals do
what do the [ __ ] libs do
oh yeah it's his fault and her fault and
his fault and his fault and her fault
and his fault
they know how to divide us
they know how they're very [ __ ] good
at it they've done it for decades how do
you think we are where we are now
because they're good at dividing us
the fascists are damn good at convincing
the people who want to fight for
democracy that they're on opposite sides
there's only there's
there's only two sides right now folks
only two
only two there's only one goddamn line
and you're either you're either on one
side or the other you're either a
fascist and you want to tear down our
democracy or your pro-democracy and you
want to preserve it that's it
we're not federalist and anti-federalist
anymore get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] states right [ __ ] oh well the
states rights the federal government's
rights blah blah blah blah blah get out
of here with that [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out
of here with that [ __ ]
we are not divided federalist
anti-federalists in this country anymore
that is all [ __ ]
and to say that the state has the right
to take away women's rights
to take away human rights get the [ __ ]
out of here we done did this [ __ ] with
slavery oh slavery's about states rights
civil war wasn't about slavery it's
about states rights yeah states rights
to
grant human beings to own other human
beings
that's what the civil war is about is
slavery
this fight here is not about [ __ ]
states rights i'm gonna show you a god
damn clip of what they're gonna do with
these states rights next
the state's rights to take women's vote
away from them the state's rights to
kill gay marriage the state's rights to
kill
interracial marriage and i use the word
kill specifically
i'm using that word intentionally folks
they're ready
they're ready have you seen the videos
of these people saying when can we shoot
them at charlie kirk's events when can
we shoot them when can we start shooting
these people
have you seen the comments on twitter on
facebook on tick tock on instagram
we have a choice folks
and rather rather you participate and
engage with your feet in our democracy
or not you're choosing
you're choosing if you choose not to
engage if you choose to just cover your
eyes and say you know what
what's done is done
then you're choosing autocracy because
that's the choice
autocracy or democracy
and they want you to choose
i mean they want you to quit
they want you to give up
they want you to not fight
they want autocracy over democracy
that's what they want they're ready
they're willing to fight they're they're
up on the hill
they picked their hill to die on
we going to stand down in the valley and
try to coax them down in the valley to
have a
a real nice conversation with us
try to convince them that oh well your
ideas suck
we have so much better line item bills
we got all kinds of bills that we want
to pass we want to cancel student debt
stay down in the valley stay down in the
valley and try to convince that the
fascists to come down
and talk to you about canceling your
student debt
or we can all look at each other and go
you know what the only way to cancel
student debt
the only way to cancel student debt
is to absolutely destroy with our ballot
this scourge of fascism in our country
we
the people can do that
we can decide
yes we have our differences and yes we
may blame this person or that person or
this person but we ain't got time for
that kind of [ __ ]
we do not have time for that [ __ ]
and while they're standing around
trying to figure out who leaked this
decision as if that's what [ __ ]
matters
oh man
who leaked it forget about the liberty
being taken away from americans
and human beings human rights
forget about that forget about that we
want to know who leaked this information
and gave
and gave women in this country and
protesters in this country and
pro-democracy people in this country a
head start
that's what they're scared of
doubt me
so what are you going to do you're going
to stand around fighting with each other
over which democrats going to cancel
student debt which democrats going to
not cancel student debt are you going to
do that are you going to go fight the
fascism
i want to cancel student debt do you
well we ain't gonna do that [ __ ] you
think these [ __ ] are gonna
cancel your student debt
they may cancel your right to [ __ ]
live
they're already doing it with women
right now as we speak
they want to cancel the right of women
to live
you don't even get to have a life-saving
medical procedure
there's a long history of the pro-life
movement in this country
long history
the ins and outs the bigotry
the way they used abortion as a cudgel
to divide us to gain political power
to press their systematic racism
to press their anti-woman views on the
entire country
and we have fought back for decades
and fought back and fought back and
fought back
and now
now is not the time
to stop fighting
and using our weapon of the ballot
to win
this battle because folks it's a battle
they're not going to stop they're not
going to quit they're not going to
it's not going to happen
and they're not going to stop at
overturning roe v wade oh they'll be
excited it'll be gross as [ __ ]
that they're going to be cheering that
americans had their liberties stripped
away from them
but they're not going to stop
not at the red states they'll come for
the blue states
they'll come for the 19th amendment mark
my words
they'll chip away and chip away and chip
away
they're not going to want women to vote
are you kidding me not at this point
goddamn women are going to try to vote
to codify roe v wade
if you're pro-democracy out there and
you are hearing my voice
it is time
it is time to band together
with anyone who will stand with the
pro-democracy people in this country and
who will fight
to save
our democracy
which is the shining city on the hill of
western democracy
because ultimately
it's not just us that's at stake
all around the world
they're women they're human beings human
rights at stake
and it's up to us
it may be up to us
to show them how important those human
rights are
here in this country
where we
say
our intention is life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness
we have to prove it
and today is the day to start proving it
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
i guess it's very clear but i'm
absolutely [ __ ] infuriated
with the news
at the united states supreme court
that's bought and paid for by the
fascists in this country
is going to overturn women's liberty
just like that
and i'm sure my co-host gabe sanchez
here has a few words he'd like to say
and gabe we got a lot of video that i i
want to get to today um there's some
video from in outside the supreme court
i think everybody needs to see uh what's
happening there i also have um some
other videos that are very relevant to
this topic that i'd like to show a
couple creators on twitter that i found
some videos that they they gave their
opinion and i think it's very important
to hear that we are two men
we cannot we we
we as men cannot receive any kind of
medical procedure that would be
considered an abortion yeah
and we
as men should not be telling women what
the [ __ ] to do
with their bodies inside the doctor's
office where they're making choices
about their bodies and their health we
should not be doing that type of [ __ ]
now what we should be doing
for sure
is standing up for women's rights to
make those decisions
inside their private physician's office
for themselves their body and their
choice
and i know i know you're on the side of
women's liberty because you are
pro-democracy
but tell us tell tell me how you felt
um when you heard this decision
yesterday
uh when the supreme court when the
decision leaked out
that they would be overturning roe v
wade
i mean honestly uh after i heard i mean
i was like you know i think it was the
utter shock if i was i was on twitter i
was like oh look at all these crazy
things that people are wearing at the
met gala and then all of a sudden this
news dropped about you know this
this draft which has now been confirmed
as legitimate
um
was uh that was that was confirmed this
morning correct right that was confirmed
this morning i it was a complete 180 in
terms of kind of like my mindset or like
my my state of mind in that moment
and the immediate
turnaround was just to discuss right we
all know that this is something that has
been talked about you know the the
the belief was that it was going to be
chipped away little by little it wasn't
going to be some outright decision that
was going to say oh you know what this
should never have been the case it
should never have been applied it should
be illegal
um
uh and i you know i i certainly wasn't
expecting that to happen
quite so abruptly right and i think a
lot of people feel the same way
um
and i mean the same for the same reason
right like i you know as i live in a
house with my girlfriend my
significant other like
i as a man
nothing goes
poorly in terms of the the rights of
protection that i have right but when it
comes to her
you know there are small things luckily
we live in california right where we
even had newsome last night say
we're going to do whatever we can
to protect
uh women's rights
in california right we're going to move
independently of what the supreme court
will decide ultimately unless they
change their opinion and protect the
rights of women in the state of
california now obviously
all
all all states aren't the same way but
for
for people like my my girlfriend or
other women in this country like we have
we as men we cannot relate
to
to their situation right like
there is certain pain and suffering
and experiences that we as men we just
cannot relate we can we can we can
sympathize with them and we can say that
we support them but ultimately we don't
know the
the same impact or effects that
uh that they have on their own bodies
because
of the supreme court or because of
fascist you know
rulers or leaders within our country
decide that they at a flip of women you
know you don't get to vote anymore you
don't get to have their say you don't
you don't get to have control of your
body anymore like we truly are
regressing to a state where other other
countries
other nations around the world look at
us
and
and are confused
laugh in in embarrassment
um because they're associated with us
but also just
ashamed at how far we've come to only
take steps back right one step forward
ten steps back and that's what it feels
like and that's what i feel like when i
read this this draft last night i was
like
i always knew that this was a
possibility of them coming after you
know
eventually
but never did i think that we would hit
2021 and 2022 this accelerant
a removal of rights from women
and just non-white men in this country
and it's it's absolutely disgusting and
it's heart-wrenching
to to know women
and say
oh you know what
they decided that you don't have the
same rights as me anymore right like not
only do we have women who aren't paid as
much
right in the workplace and don't have
actual
all we're asking for is that women and
men are equal right
but for some reason right we all know
the reasons why but for some reason
uh republicans white
old men
they just feel like obviously that's a
threat to their own masculinity and and
and their own manly hood right
and
it's disgusting
it is disgusting that
that people who are so threatened and
also so hypocritical
are willing to take
things away from others right
they they they project this christianity
and we're evangelicals we love each
other right we love children well [ __ ]
the kid
you know as as george carlin said they
they love a kid
as long as you're pregnant but as soon
as the baby comes out
[ __ ] them they're off right
we're gonna watch that video by the way
and you look at the situation right now
it is insane
it is insane to believe that we are
truly at a point in our in our advanced
civilization
that we were removing rights from people
and again the these republicans project
their own christianity
and say oh you know what do unto others
as you would want to be done unto you
right you you gotta you gotta care for
others you gotta give them shelter you
gotta give them food you gotta make you
gotta take care of the sick right and
the needy
and then you have this where you where
you have a justice that says oh you know
what
uh this should never been the case at
all you shouldn't have these rights you
should have the kid you shouldn't have
any right to your own body or any say in
terms of what happens and how you got
there right
and then you got marjorie taylor green
last night she makes a video she goes oh
my god with her [ __ ] crocodile tears
and says oh
this is our god like she shared a photo
on twitter today saying our god is
greater whatever the [ __ ] that was [ __ ]
it was about what the [ __ ] was that
but last night she makes a video with
her crocodile tears saying oh my god
this is exactly what we've wanted
millions of babies are going to be saved
because millions of unborn children have
been killed shut the [ __ ] up
you're a woman who who hypocritically
says you're christian but goes and has
an affair with two men
and then you say you're you're you're a
messenger of god and you're someone
who's gonna protect the rights of others
shut the [ __ ] up
this is this is the gqp
this is the gqp this is where they stand
and everyone um
of course is surprised i want to show a
tweet here
from
um someone that we've had on the show
karen ignivolo kfa from legal af um she
said before yesterday i would have
thought that this video
was dramatic fear-mongering i can't
believe this is about to become reality
i can't even watch handmaid's tale
anymore because it's no longer
entertainment the video that she's
talking about
is a video from midas touch you guys
know we're midas touch partners
we air on the midas touch facebook page
um this is their video here
and i want to play it here there is one
i i want one note i want to say because
i remember talking to him about this
video and they even said when we
released this video last year or i think
2020 or 2021 i forget where when exactly
they released it but
uh they said
we got so much [ __ ] right with this
video people said that's the extreme
this will never happen right right these
are the same people that you know are
[ __ ] don't show up to the ballot type
people uh you know what he'll never be
elected it'll never happen it'll never
get that far it's fear-mongering tony
they won't come after the 19th amendment
they won't come after women's right to
vote they won't come after contraception
they won't come after marriage equality
they won't come after that bull [ __ ]
[ __ ] they're ready they're ready they're
ready they're they're already got their
court that they think will overturn
every decision that that you think they
won't come after
and this video this video encapsula
encapsulates what they're wanting to do
and they've made america that they want
to live in
yeah you give them an inch man these the
[ __ ] are going to take a mile
so let's watch this video because
in a few months
in a few months in states all around
this country
this will be this will be the reality
listen everything's gonna be okay
i got my sound off sorry about that let
me
fix the sound here
listen everything's gonna be okay right
just let me do the talking okay
good evening ladies
license please
where you
headed oh we were just out for a drive
headed to the border
oh no no we were just going up to the uh
hey there
what's your name
grace
are you pregnant grace
step out of the vehicle she does not
have to yes she does
show me your hands on the wheels pretty
step out of the vehicle
[Music]
what once seemed
like something that could never happen
here we are today with the reality of
this video
and i was thinking about this video last
night um playing it here
um and you notice the line that says are
you going over the border
and you know you assume that this may be
the border of another country uh maybe
canada maybe mexico but this could be a
border to a state folks yeah
i mean literally they are creating a
cheeto dust confederacy is what they are
going to create and they're going to use
women's liberty as the weapon to create
it
that's what they're going to do they're
going to sacrifice women's liberty so
that they can have their cheeto dust
confederacy
um and and again when karen points out
that just just
just a few days ago that video that we
just watched seem like fear mongering
is the reality
the absolute reality
because the fact remains this morning
here's
here's scott
uh
mcfarland
reporting
marsha blackburn's take on the whole
thing marsha blackburn's not worried
about women's liberty here she's not
worried about americans losing their
rights the supreme court has never taken
away rights
from people they have always given
rights in their decision when they make
a landmark decision and they turn back
precedent
of other cases they don't take away
rights
they give them in this decision they're
taking away your liberty and listen to
what marsha blackburn is concerned about
this morning the court
this is someone who's done something
that is unprecedented they decided to
leak this it addresses
the
integrity of the court and i think that
it we would be well served
to give chief justice roberts the time
and space he needs to investigate this
to find out who did this
make certain that appropriate actions
are going to be taken
in addressing this
and
what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] man okay i just want to say
something here okay this
marsha blackburn you know as [ __ ]
bless your heart racist woman as she is
go please define a woman [ __ ]
[ __ ]
this is someone
who is willing to say oh you know what
we need to investigate this right now no
no i'm not going to say that this leak
was from the right or the left but i
wouldn't be surprised if this leak did
come from the right just to instill fear
and anger
and then
project some sort of
magnifying glass investigation
on the left right on the left justices
even though
i don't i mean you can make a case that
it was someone on the left but there's a
part of me deep down inside that says
i wouldn't be surprised if the right did
this as a political move to blame it on
the left and cause more divide right you
said it earlier they're good at this
they make us divide each other into two
groups that is the unfortunate reality
we live in in right now right left right
i mean there is a right versus wrong and
fascism versus [ __ ] democracy
but i look at this as someone who says
yeah we don't need to really look into
someone like clarence thomas or jenny
thomas
right we don't we don't need to
investigate justice roberts and why he
decided to
boot out there we don't need to look
into uh justice kavanaugh and the the
the allegations in in uh reports that
were coming into the fbi we don't need
to look at how his his payments were
were completely done and paid off before
he came uh into the supreme court like
this is someone who decided to put her
foot down and say you know we need to be
more [ __ ] enraged about
the leak right focus on the leak it's
president there's a leak out of the
supreme court not the unprecedented
exactly taking away liberty from from
[ __ ] human beings it's this is about
human rights and they're taking your
[ __ ] human rights away from you and
if you think they're gonna stop here you
are [ __ ] dead wrong dead wrong
uh well i wanna i wanna point out
something though because this is very
important we're gonna have dr rachel
bittikoffer on here and just and just um
hopefully at the top of the hour here
we'll have rachel with us but rachel
pointed out something this morning on
her twitter account she said trust me
there are plenty of elected republicans
crapping their pants about that draft
and here's why folks
here's why
in politics you never want you never
want to give your opposition a head
start never do you want to give your
opposition a head start especially on a
day like today when there are huge
primaries in ohio
huge primaries happening in ohio we're
going to find out just how [ __ ] thick
trumpism is in a state like ohio
today during the primary we're gonna see
if jd mandel wins his race
but here we are
here we are
talking about the republican party
taking away liberty and rachel is right
they are crapping their [ __ ] pants
and the reason why
is because they're terrified
of democracy they're terrified that the
majority will engage because they know
they're the minority folks
why else would they be doing this [ __ ]
where they buy supreme court justices to
press their religious views on the rest
of the country exactly because that's
what has happened
that is what has happened here
they want to oppress our our rights
because they feel their their religion
is better than yours or whatever
uh i have one more video um
right now that i want to show here
that is just outside the supreme court
and i want to show you i want to show
you how ready they are for this fight
folks they're they're [ __ ] ready
these people are geared up they got
their lawn chairs they got their signs
ready they got their they got they got
it ready they got their bull horns ready
they are ready for this fight they want
to die on this hill
list this is in front of the supreme
court this morning
scott mcfarlane has posted this video on
twitter um i don't know if he took it
i'm sure he did he's there at capitol
hill
um but this is front of the supreme
court now listen to the cries
watch
who's out there protesting
oh
lord we thank you for life today
lord we thank you that you sent your son
that would all of us could have life
eternal father we thank you that you
knew us before we were i mean besides
the women that would have a medical
procedure that would save their life
forget those forget those like but
here's the point i want to make to
everyone out there listening
is
they're acting like they lost
do you notice that they're hey hey ho ho
roe v wade has got to go the word is
that roe v wade is gone
yeah and they're out there still
fighting as if they lost
do you know why do you know why
do you know why they won this decision
do you know why because they
will fight
they will fight
and they will continue they will not
stop at abortion they will not stop at
contraception they will not stop at your
marriage equality they will not stop at
your right to vote they will not stop no
matter what victories they run into they
will continue to degrade and chip away
at our rights our liberty and our
democracy because they want a fascist
state
and if you think that them winning this
decision is going to get them to stop
you are out of your [ __ ] mind
it should give you no more cause than to
hit the streets
hit the tweets and hit the streets
if you want to if you want to get uh
rhymey with it
if you want to have a good phrase hit
the tweets hit the streets
it's time to push back on these type of
protests now there are protests this
morning in front of the supreme court
that are that are pro-choice and
pro-women
and pro-liberty protest
but the point i'm trying to make here is
they're not just counting this as a
victory and going home and saying well
we won we're going to take our trophy
and go home they're going to act like
they lost folks
they're going to act like they lost
they expect us to fight
and if we don't we're really [ __ ]
screwed yeah we are really [ __ ]
screwed
so let's fight um
gabe did you have anything you wanted to
say about that video i've got uh another
video that i want to play here no i was
just the only thing i was going to add
was you know they've been there since
that
that draft was leaked right like what i
what i know from what i was reading
online was
the barricade you mean you mean the
anti-abortion the anti-choice the
anti-woman movement is that what you're
saying yeah yeah uh ever since the the
draft leaked
for the anti-woman anti-abortion just
anti-rights
uh decision was was leaked um they set
up those barricades right away they they
anticipated people to show up they
anticipated people to protest whether
for or against but people have been
there since last night since it leaked
there have been people that have you
know shown up with science and protested
and have been sitting there all night i
saw a photo from last night at like two
in the morning and they were sitting
down and you know had their candles had
their lights waiting you know peacefully
peacefully
protesting um and waiting outside the
steps
for today right and tomorrow and the
next day like there you know yes some of
these people have already admitted
defeat and said it you know it's already
it's already gone but some people are
like nah [ __ ] this man it hasn't been
decided this is just this is just a
draft now you could say that it is like
we're working in the ultimate when kind
of reality right now not an if but a
when there is the possibility that one
justice could be swayed and turn over
based on dissenting opinions from the
other justices now i don't know how
likely that actually is or what type of
outside influence can actually have on a
justice to turn over against alito
however
it is a possibility because this draft
is not the official decision yet
uh but we shouldn't act as if it is and
we shouldn't act right like it isn't in
the sense of like oh well we're fine we
can just we're good we don't need to
[ __ ] go and burn this [ __ ]
down no
no we should right you should do that
all the way to the ground scorched earth
folks we have to get divisive here and i
know i know a lot of people don't like
to hear that oh tony you're saying
divisive that is exactly what we have to
do
there there is a clear clear enemy to
our democracy and our liberty and our
rights
this is not some hyperbolic [ __ ]
where you're like oh well they're not
they're not going to take away your
rights right bull [ __ ] [ __ ] i want to
show you a video here of a sitting
united states senator from indiana
who is saying the next thing he wants to
take away is your equality to marriage
listen to this the states ought to
express themselves and i'm not saying
that rule would apply in general
depending on the topic but it should
mostly be in general because it's hard
to have it on issues that you just are
interested in when you deny it for
others with a different point of view
so you would be okay with the supreme
court leaving the question of
interracial marriage to the states
yes i think so he's saying here that he
would prefer
that the states decide the cheeto dust
confederacy to decide whether you can
marry who you love
that is what he's [ __ ] saying
right and don't doubt them when they say
these things they are fascist and they
are ready to take away your liberty and
i'm telling you this morning they are
really [ __ ] scared about this leak
but they are really excited they are
really excited that they finally were
able to buy enough supreme court
justices to start taking away people's
liberty
the people they hate yeah even on the
topic of of marriage equality right like
we we hit a
you know with prop 8 equality for
same-sex marriage [ __ ] finally right and
now we're working against that but also
even the idea of interracial marriage
being
uh at risk and up to the states right we
know how many you know
let's say southern states uh you know
below the bible belt would probably say
you don't have the same rights anymore
we want to bring it back to you know
crazy you know something like three
fifths like it'd be insane but also not
unrealistic but then you've got people
like clarence thomas who is an
interracial marriage with the
insurrectionist jenny thomas but you
look at that and he looks at the
dissenting opinion of
alito and goes
yeah well you know what happy wife happy
life like that's the type of reality he
lives in where he doesn't
now who knows maybe he is going to make
a decision that says
you know uh only in an abortion
situation should we restrict these
rights but not in a further like
uh uh marriage equality type of right i
don't know what his actual opinion is
gonna be once he once he writes it down
but what i will say is like for someone
who is an interracial marriage who is on
the bench
i am both
not surprised and completely shocked by
the fact that
this guy would allow this to happen
right because his own
well-being in life is actually
at risk if you give it up to the states
there's a potential that they say no you
know what we don't see you guys as the
same anymore so this marriage is null
and void
like what is that right are states
rights more important than human rights
are they no what are they that [ __ ] well
i mean that's what that's where we're at
here oh i know right i mean it is insane
to think that your gun has more rights
than a woman like we already knew that
based on how legislation was but this is
an official
draft of someone that goes yeah well you
know what
guns were in the constitution what the
[ __ ] is that [ __ ] like that's that's
that's the that is the opinion
of a justice who is looking for
how to decide the the betterment of our
country how to decide laws and policies
to say this should be allowed and they
shouldn't be allowed this is a human
right
can i tell you something about the
second amendment here
um
all you gun nuts out there and send this
to your gun nut friends maybe i'll cut
this clip out let me tell you something
you white [ __ ]
white privileged [ __ ] who love
to run around talking about your first
and second amendment and don't know any
other amendment past that and don't even
know what the first and second says if
you let these [ __ ] take away
women's liberty they're coming for your
first and second amendment you dumb
[ __ ] they're coming for it you
don't
you don't think that these fascists when
they have the chance to repeal the
second amendment or repeal the second
amendment you goddamn right they will
they'll take away your [ __ ] guns
you don't
i mean they're they're haphazardly
taking away
decisions that a woman makes with their
doctor what makes you think that these
fascists won't take away your guns they
won't take away your right to speak are
you kidding me they want your first
amendment gone they want your second
amendment gone they want the 14th and
13th amendment gone they want the 19th
amendment gone they want it gone because
they want control they're so [ __ ]
privileged and so [ __ ] oppressed they
are they were bitching about wearing a
mask to keep people safe and they were
bitching about not getting a vaccine the
choice that they made because they
couldn't go get a [ __ ] hamburger
you don't think that they will scourge
away your rights and take them away and
stomp on them and [ __ ] all over our
constitution
so you second amendment dumb [ __ ] out
there that yell and scream about your
right to own guns and 2a and oh it's a
terran protect us from a tyrannical
government you mean a fascist state yep
you mean a fascist state i don't think
you understand what the road you're
marching down on is
democrats aren't going to take away your
[ __ ] guns that's been some all kinds
of [ __ ] for 30 goddamn years bill
clinton was gonna take your gun for
eight years barack obama's gonna take
your guns for eight years joe biden's
gonna take your [ __ ] guns shut the
[ __ ] up i'll tell you he's going to take
your guns the [ __ ] fascist the people
who want to take your [ __ ] liberty
that are taking your liberty that want
to take your rights away that is who
will take your [ __ ] guns that's who
will take the second amendment away from
you in a heartbeat they'll take away
your vote in a heartbeat they don't give
two shits you think when the
constitution is [ __ ] on and they rip it
up and tear it and throw it in the
toilet and flush that [ __ ] you
think they're do you think they're going
to preserve the first and second
amendment get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] if you are for liberty and you
are for democracy in that constitution
you should be absolutely [ __ ]
infuriated no matter how you feel about
abortion this morning
you should be infuriated that these
justices who were bought and paid for by
the federalist society are overturning
women's liberty you should be [ __ ]
infuriated if you are pro-democracy and
if you're not infuriated this morning
about the decision that the federal
society that a that a [ __ ] fascist
court would would rain down and take
away the rights of people in this
country human rights
you are not pro-democracy you are a
fascist if you are saying oh states
rights oh babies are being killed blah
blah blah you
you
are a [ __ ]
fascist and it's obvious now yeah where
we stand so if you like your second
amendment you think your guns are cool
and all that [ __ ]
just consider the fact if they're
willing to take away women's right to
choose medical procedures
where your rights for guns stand for you
[ __ ] shitty morons
i'm just saying i'm just saying i mean
you're not wrong you know no people look
at this and like oh they're just banning
math books they're just banning yes
they're just banning that like oh it's
just a it's just a light censorship
that's all that it is it's like
you you know what happens right we go
from light to full-on hard for this [ __ ]
right and that's what the republicans
say they go oh no no don't worry about
it it's just this like right it's
inappropriate kids shouldn't learn about
it they shouldn't read it they shouldn't
see it and then what happens is you
don't have it in your life at all but
they say well you know what we've gone
so long and and so far without this
thing in your life you know you don't
even need it anymore there's you know
what let's just let's just redline this
out of the thing right we're going to
take education who needs education
anyway i mean we don't even need public
education i mean really we've diluted it
down that they don't even learn math
anymore because of critical race theory
so who needs education they'll take it
away from you
they'll take it away from you speaking
speaking of [ __ ] boneheads
taking away [ __ ] from people
uh i wonder if susan collins is willing
to take back her word here i guess she
made some statements this morning but
this is back when brett kavanaugh was
being confirmed
that you know you know what i'm talking
about you know i'm talking about brett
kavanaugh yeah yeah the guy the guy who
yeah the guy who is accused of rape the
rapist who was bought and paid for
someone paid his debt i don't know who
it was but someone paid his [ __ ] debt
mr justice uh i love beer right he loves
beer and he definitely won't overturn
roe v wade let's listen to that [ __ ] box
susan collins
i do not believe that brett kavanaugh
will overturn presidents are overturned
he noted that roe had been reaffirmed 19
years later by planned parenthood versus
casey
and that it was precedent on president
he said it should be extremely rare that
it be overturned and it should be an
example you have obviously full
confidence i do we talked about whether
he considered road to be settled law
he said that he agreed with what justice
roberts said at his nomination hearing
in which he said that it was settled law
i
could not vote for a judge who had
demonstrated hostility to roe v wade
because
it would indicate a lack of respect for
president
what judge kavanaugh told me and he's
the first supreme court nominee that
i've interviewed out of six who has told
me this is that he views precedent not
just as a legal doctrine but is rooted
in our constitution and he reveres our
constitution i so either either and i'm
gonna stop it here because i'm tired of
listening to this [ __ ] [ __ ] box um
and and maine i don't know i don't know
what your recall laws up there but you
really should look into them and recall
this [ __ ] idiot and get rid of this
this [ __ ] fool because we got a few
more years of this [ __ ] and maine
should really look into the recall laws
to see if they can recall this is also
coming from a woman who said she was
only going to run for two terms 12 years
she said that was enough time for me to
run right well here's the other thing
here's the other thing here's the other
thing is either she's lying or brett
kavanaugh is lying did you catch that
she said oh brett kavanaugh says he's
not going to overturn roe v wade i
interviewed him he gave me his
reassurance that the constitution
matters president matters and decisions
matter well she's either lying or he's
lying so that's the question that the
press should be asking susan collins
this morning were you lying or was brett
kavanaugh lying because someone's
someone's [ __ ] lying
and that's that's the way the media
doesn't handle it because this morning
you're like oh well susan collins blah
blah blah and she has a vote and she's a
senator and she was elected she was
either [ __ ] lying or brett kavanaugh
was lying there's not two ways around
this [ __ ] no not at all i mean i i look
at it because it's not not just
kavanaugh it's gorsuch too she said both
people told her straight faced and she
believed in full confidence now whether
she couldn't see the [ __ ] evil smirk
and grin on their face and the crossed
fingers in their hand but i can tell you
this much either she's a dumb [ __ ] and
an idiot yep yep oh
she knew exactly what was happening yeah
you have that you know
i'll you know maybe i won't be around
anymore no one will have to look at me
or blame you for the situation but she
put she put her name to it and people
questioned her and she said in two
different instances in 2018
these guys said it was settled law
they said they weren't going to
challenge it that it was established and
that's what it was
but we all knew what was happening we
all knew
what they were there for right
her or
uh kavanaugh gorsuch amy coney barrett
like we we know exactly what their role
is and what they were brought in for the
purpose
and they did exactly what they were
supposed to and they'll continue to do
what they were told to do by the federal
society
and the extreme right-wing fascist
christian
so it's like
it bugs the [ __ ] out of me
because you look at someone like like
susan collins who who just says yeah you
know what they told me it was settled
and it was done
and i took him for their word
well you're either again a [ __ ] idiot
and a [ __ ]
or you knew exactly what was gonna
happen
and you straight face lied to everyone
else
i want to play
because um i think it's important to get
because we're going to have dr rachel
bittikov around here in just a second
but i want to play a video of jojo from
jurors jojo from jers is a friend of the
show
she's been on our show we've done some
content with jojo you guys know the
letters from trucker convoy uh joe is
the
is the voice of tammy um she's actually
the one who wrote those who wrote those
um scripts which is they're [ __ ]
hilarious by the way um but joe
uh posted this video last night and i
want to give everyone a chance because
um i think the most important voices
right now are just not allies of men who
are [ __ ] infuriated that you would
take our wives our mothers our daughters
our our our nieces
rights away from them
but we should listen to women this
opinion about this so i'm going to play
this video from joe and listen to the
end even though joe's upset here listen
to her message at the end
i'm having flashbacks to 2016
when people who couldn't vote for the
email lady said to me
calm down relax you're being so dramatic
row is canon they're not going to touch
row there's good people in place who are
going to check his worst impulses and by
the way he's not even really
you know pro-life or as i call them
anti-choice so like calm down relax
and then the guy who bragged about
sexually assaulting women
got three
lifetime
appointments to the supreme court
guided by the federalist society he got
one federalist
one
sexual predator who's in hawk to god
knows who
and a handmaiden
and they all made it very clear
what their intentions were
and here we are
federal protections for
a woman's residues are about to end
i want that world for myself i just
really don't want that world for my
daughter
how we come so far
as a society
men
we have to fight
we have to fight like hell
because this is just the beginning it's
only going to get worse
i'm not going to give up
nobody should give up we have to fight
harder than ever
and that is what we should do is we
should fight and fight like hell
and use the weapon of the ballot to make
sure
that we save our democracy not just for
ourselves dudes out there who are
scratching your nut sack but for the
women who gave you that ball sack
for the women for the women who will run
this country eventually and i think
that's where we really need to get to
because this is the reason why we're in
the position that we're in and joe
points it out because men are just
[ __ ] trash they're [ __ ] garbage
and they need to stop having control
over anything
yeah just because they destroy is what
they do i'm sorry guys out there who
might be offended i'm a liberal guy but
to be quite honest with you that's what
men do they [ __ ] destroy
yeah and you know what
let's not just destroy man it's destroy
and then blame others
it's a person who's not white what gabe
what was she wearing what was she
wearing
you know what did she have on
you know how how can we trust her she's
got emotions she has this thing every
month how how how could we possibly do
that
guys out there if you're an ally
it's time for you to [ __ ] fight for
women
everywhere i don't give a [ __ ] what race
it is i don't care it's time
now to fight because they're coming for
you they're coming for your daughters
they're coming for your wives your
sisters your nieces they're coming for
your mother they're coming for
you and your family
doubt me
doubt me thank you joe for your message
um what a message it is and um
maybe we'll replay it again on the show
because
um it hits hard but it should hit hard
and we should not look away uh speaking
of that let's go to a break i want to
show you uh everyone enjoy the break
here this is the trucker convoy video
that joe wrote and joe's voice in this
video is tammy right after this stick
around after this break we're gonna have
dr rachel bittikoffer we're gonna get
another woman's opinion on this matter
because i think it's important to have
women's opinion on this matter and we're
gonna we're gonna evaluate a video of a
woman's opinion in kentucky
so stick around right after this break
dr rachel bittikoffer remember jojo is
tammy in this hilarious hilarious video
letters of the trucker convoy stick
around we'll be right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
yours
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lid
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] a [ __ ]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for staying to the break
one of our favorite videos there
featuring jojo from jers
go watch the video that joe made last
night over and over and over again send
it to your friends send it to your
allies know that as sad as this is
we are still in the fight rachel dr
biddikover how are you this morning
man i'm feeling that intro [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] yes yes yes
ma'am yes ma'am so we've seen this
decision from the supreme court and
there's a lot of stuff i want to talk to
you about but this i think this is going
to be the issue that really um takes
over our political body here
and yeah and i i think i think the fact
that that uh quote-unquote conservatives
which are fascists now they're not
conservative anymore that are willing
willing to to stand up and cheer for the
fact that they're going to take away
human rights away from people in this
country that we're going to turn back
the clock on what rights and what
liberty is going to be extended to other
humans in this country i think it's
[ __ ] vile and despicable and we
should point it out and we should go we
should go fight them on that hill we
should not try to coax them down in the
valley and and you know play nice with
them and try to figure out how we're
gonna how we're gonna cancel student
debt with the fascists that are trying
to take away your liberty [ __ ] that [ __ ]
let's go up and let's fight them against
let's fight for democracy let's do that
um and i'm gonna show a video here but i
want you to give us your opinion of this
decision that came down last night how
do you view it
yeah like i said when this when this
memo leaked and i read through it
the conversation i think appropriately
was focused oh okay this is a complete
and total gut of roe okay this is this
is such a complete and total gut bro
that that that the the things that the
republican party will be able to do on
in in terms of of policy i mean it's
just starting with abortion but going
down
through things like gay marriage
are just gonna be astounding right and
it really is going to for the first time
illustrate the difference of living in a
red state versus a blue state because i
would expect we'll see forced birth
bills um coming out of these gop
legislatures
that go much beyond these these initial
things they've been challenging in the
courts these six week and 15 week bans
were conditioned on the fundamental
finding that women had a
constitutionally protected right to
abortion
once that's stricken down that means
that they can go and outright ban
abortion
completely ban it with no exceptions and
they can also um you know go after
things like plan b which i think a lot
of women uh and this was one of my
concerns with this issue is that a lot
of women look at abortion now especially
the voting part of the
electorate and they think about things
like options like plan b and their less
concerned but this i think is going to
uh really put the issue on the on the
radar of women all across the country
well i i think those are good points
because i think i think there's 18
states is what i was reading this
morning that basically have trigger
bills um bills that are waiting in their
lat
and they're already passed in law
basically once roe is is done
they become enacted which means that um
there are forced birth bills at that
point you know they're known as trigger
bills meaning they're triggered by the
abolishment of this roe v wade decision
um also people are pointing out the
planned parenthood and casey decision
also today um now i think you're right
in that we're gonna have a clear
division in states um and i think i'm
gonna call it and i've been calling it
the cheeto dust confederacy because
that's where
really where we're at is that they want
to create fascist states we've seen ron
desantis in florida we've seen greg
abbott in texas we've seen missouri
kentucky tennessee they've all tried
this um and i want to play a video here
from the legislator in tennessee i think
this is from a while ago
um but let's just watch and then we'll
comment on the other side explain my
novo yes ma'am
you know i'm a diagnostic radiologist
and diagnostic radiologist
historically and in many places in this
state still
do all of the first trimester ob
ultrasound
so i am extraordinarily
partially familiar with the development
of a fetus in the womb
and for you to sit here and say that at
15 weeks a fetus has a functional heart
a four-chamber heart that can survive on
its own is fallacious
that is not true there is no viability
you know it it
i look around at my colleagues on this
committee
i am the only one men on
this podium right now i am the only
physician sitting on this podium
this bill is a medical sham
it does not follow medicine it does not
even purport to listen to medicine
and for each and every one of my
colleagues
to be so willing
to cast and i vote
when what you are doing is putting your
finger putting your knee
putting your
a gun to women's heads you are killing
women
because abortion will continue
women will continue to have efficacy
over their own bodies
whether or not you make it legal
i vote no and i really
really apologize to the people in
kentucky that we are spending this much
time and this much energy when we have
families in poverty we have single
women heading households in poverty at a
higher rate than any other group in the
state
and you all are not addressing that you
all are making it worse
thank you
she was being very kind when she says
thank you at the end there i think
this is uh senator berg
of
kentucky now this is back from march
just this year and i'm sure people even
then were like oh you're you're
completely out of step you're you're
hysterical you're you're making claims
that there's no way bull [ __ ]
[ __ ]
their their
goal
is to make it to where women do not have
the right to choose what they can and
can't do with their bodies and senator
berg brilliantly points it out here
they're gonna do with their bodies what
they want whether it's legal or safe
it's going to happen
yeah i mean in a pure politics way tony
and gabe let me be clear
this is the worst [ __ ] thing that
could ever happen to the republican
party because what you saw there was a
very spirited and to us very compelling
explanation of why these these uh
viability bans were problematic but now
the gop has been in an instant relieved
of the responsibility of of threading
viability casey's viability it's been
overturned with this memo row which is
the basic right to privacy that that
your right to abortion access is founded
on is eviscerated and so what we're
really going to see now when we see
we'll talk about forced birth bills we
mean every [ __ ] one everyone will be
forced to give birth okay not just poor
women not women who can't travel out of
state in time not women who you know
don't know what to do for too long and
exceed a viability man we are talking
about every [ __ ] woman rich or poor
and they're making it very clear that
they intend to hold people criminally
responsible who try to flee these laws
so this is a [ __ ] 10 alarm fire in
terms of
rights for women human rights and i will
also say one more thing before i jump
back off and that is this it is true
that women have a special disposition to
talk about this issue guys but we're
since we are talking about a complete
and total evisceration of our
constitutional freedom the i would argue
that actually voices like yours and
gabe's tony are so [ __ ] critical
right now because if it's just women
that get pissed off then we're not going
to have the momentum that we need to
stop this we need every [ __ ] man that
cares about his sisters his daughters
his wives his cousins the women that he
knows to get angry and get angry now
i appreciate you coming rachel i really
really do we always love having you here
um you are always welcome back and i
know i know there's going to be more on
this issue and more on other issues and
i know you're very busy trying to make
sure
that uh that we can win for our
democracy and because there's only one
party right now that is pro-democracy
and it is more obvious now this morning
than it was yesterday yeah and it's
gonna continue to get more and more
obvious and i'm gonna show a video after
you leave of of what what the republican
party thinks just to what you said
of what they want women and how they
want to criminalize this um so rachel
thank you for joining us i really do
appreciate it come back anytime we will
see you very soon my friend we're gonna
go to a break we'll stick around me and
gabe will be right back right after this
thank you rachel
bye boys see ya
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
troopests mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thank you dr rachel biddickhoffer for
joining us
give your take on the politics of it
i think rachel's right i actually think
republicans
may have handed pro-democracy people
just just the fight that they need and
want right
to to make sure to push back on fascism
because now they've i mean they've shown
us right out in the open who they truly
are with this right yeah i mean
not hiding anymore no i have heard out
loud with trump that that that that
really almost
at this point doesn't even matter
they're really truly showing you exactly
what they wanted to do why trump was
their weapon he's a [ __ ] buffoon and
that's why they want him back in because
he's a great weapon because he'll do
whatever they want
he is he is uh he is the dog and the
tail will the fascist tail will wag it
um and i want to point something out
here and speaking of tail wagging the
dog
for people who don't know this is a nazi
his name is nick fuentes okay
nick fuentes has appeared with several
members of congress at his nazi rallies
and i'm not being hyperbolic here this
guy is a [ __ ] nazi yep he he he's a
holocaust denier he hates he's an
anti-semite he's a [ __ ] nazi
and
you see the af in the bottom let me take
this you see the af here that stands for
america first if you're wondering what
marjorie taylor green and matt gatz and
donald trump are out or out
traveling all around the country
spreading around their nazi nickel poop
nazi ways listen to what this
[ __ ] says about women who have
abortions this is the leader of their
party folks
this nick fuentes is the leader of their
party don't don't doubt me he's he's in
bed with paul gozar
he loves marjorie taylor green marjorie
taylor green doesn't know exactly who he
is she can't recall she's like oh i i i
didn't look into him before i showed up
to that nazi little conference that he
had this guy is pushing
republican gqp fascist kid diddler
messaging listen to what he says about
what he wants to have happen to women
the woman should be put in jail too they
should all go to jail a hundred years
for the doctor a thousand years for the
woman that's what
let me replay it again the woman should
be put in jail too they should all go to
jail a hundred years for the doctor a
thousand years for the woman that's what
i say the woman should be we're going to
play it
they should all go to jail a hundred
years for the doctor a thousand years
for the woman that's what i say the
woman should be put in jail too they
should all go to jail a hundred years
for the doctor a thousand years for the
woman that's what i say
now if you watched the [ __ ] video
from marjorie taylor green last night
and realized that she loves this guy she
loves this [ __ ] guy she loves his
nazi rallies she loves his [ __ ]
supporters she loves his followers as
well
no what the [ __ ] she is doing
know what she is doing what she is doing
is being with this this [ __ ] nazi
yeah that's what he is
uh i let me see if i can find
the video
of marjorie taylor green i don't know
the thing that that that always gets me
and last night was a great sign of this
even today uh you look at this and
everyone like hey let's get the thoughts
of experts
when it comes to women's rights
and
most if not all especially when you go
to like fox news and [ __ ] it's a bunch
of
dudes old dudes old white dudes who are
experts
experts on a panel that say what a woman
should and should not have access to and
what rights a woman should or should not
have you know
those are the people that they look to
and those are the people that
that they have out there as
as the people who what i say is truth
because i'm some doctor i'm some medical
expert i'm some person who's a
consultant or whatever the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] title is but they have them on
no women to actually discuss this it's
all men just like nick fuentes he wants
to give a hundred years to the doctor in
a thousand years for the for the woman
but then for the man who commits the
crime
of rape or incest or whatever right
no time no no no no and you know what
on top of that
they should be able to sue the women
like that's that is again we've already
covered this in past episodes this is
not we are not making any of this [ __ ]
up
this is real
this is what they have put out there
whether they want to marry kids who are
below the age of 18 whether they want to
have the ability to sue as a victim as a
male victim even though they're the
perpetrator in the crime they want to
have the ability as well as their family
members to
indefinitely sue the woman
who has the abortion
right like this is
this is insane
like we thought that this world this
dystopian future was never going to be
around right
and then here we are what we thought was
sci-fi ends up being
reality what we thought was fiction is
non-fiction
like we're not exaggerating we're not
making this [ __ ] up this is actually
what's happening
well you know that's a good point
because these ideas we've been dealing
with this in this country for a long
time
this is a clip from the great george
carlin this was back in 1996. now if
people aren't aware of like the
the history of abortion let me give you
a little history lesson here um
after roe v wade it was several years
that there was a challenge to the
supreme court an actual real challenge
to
roe v wade now in the early 1990s and
1992 there was a case planned parenthood
versus casey
it didn't overturn roe v wade which they
thought it might but at that point they
really dialed back the the protections
that women had that roe v way extended
them the constitutional protections
now in the 1990s if people don't know
this
pro-life
they
they
self-described pro-lifers in this
country were bombing abortion clinics
and killing doctors they were shooting
them murdering them assassinating them
uh dr tiller of wichita kansas is one of
the most uh infamous
uh assassinations of one of these
doctors his life was
attempt attempt assassination several
times before they were successful these
people are not pro-life um but i'm gonna
let george here mr carlin
and if you're if you're religious god
rest his soul
he's been gone for 14 years and this was
back in 1996 but this still speaks to
the problem that we're having today
listen to what the great george garland
says he says it in jokes
but i'm going to interpret it of what
the politics are and why he's saying the
line that you were alluding to earlier
uh
gabe about about being preschool you're
[ __ ] in other words and and what
george carlin's saying here the the
opening joke
about you know people who are are
against abortion are people you wouldn't
want to [ __ ] in the first place um that
joke goes all the way back to the late
60s george garland wrote that joke um
and he used it in several of his shows
to actually open the show a lot of shows
that he would go to that was one of his
opening jokes and it was to get your
[ __ ] attention is what he's trying to
do with that joke and it does a really
good job of getting your attention
because he's about to tell you something
really [ __ ] important about the the
social economical and political uh
position of the country now remember
this is the the the mid 1990s and he's
talking about conservatives you notice
he doesn't say republicans because back
back in the 1990s we still were in the
fight of the anti-federalist verse the
federalist we're not in that position
today the republican party has
successfully made themselves the fascist
party so now it's autocracy versus
democracy not not anti-federalist versus
federalist
that isn't the fight
but george does a great job of pointing
out here
that republicans conservatives fascists
these days give a lot of shits
about the the uterus of a woman and that
the fetus from conception to nine months
they give a whole lot of [ __ ] about it
right but they don't give two shits
about that child when that child is born
oh yeah and that's the [ __ ] truth
actually they they give not two [ __ ]
that they would love to be able to marry
it even in some states at this point so
let's continue what george says here um
because what he says about being
pro-life is very important some uh
trumpers or fascist uh you know uh nazis
and maga hats really is what they are at
this point uh back then they were still
then bailing their fascism with the word
conservative right um nowadays we know
that that was all [ __ ] but what
george is alluding to here is they
really don't give a [ __ ] about the life
of the child they don't give a [ __ ]
about the life uh that they consider oh
life begins at conception and all this
nonsense which we know today to be
factually
way way off the map and weigh against
science and weigh against what actual
life is and what viable life is but that
doesn't matter anymore and the reason
why it doesn't matter anymore and the
reason why they've always wanted to get
away from roe v wade and they wanted to
destroy roe v wade is be so you don't
have to have those arguments like rachel
was saying right they don't want to have
to have the life argument folks they
don't they don't want
they don't want you to give the argument
of the human being's life that is
actually has the womb has the fetus that
has the uterus that is
is making decisions about their body and
their pregnancy and their family they do
not want to talk about that life that's
why they've always been pissed off about
roe v wade because here's the history of
the pro-life movement the one thing that
they've never done gabe they've never
done is they've never turned their shiv
to the woman they always always have
blamed the providers always have made
the providers the enemies
they were the baby killers not the women
and that with this decision is going to
change
the provide there will be no providers
there will be no providers there won't
be providers there will only be women
seeking possible life
changing uh life-saving
medical care
and they
they will be the enemy
let's finish what george says here
because i believe go ahead gabe did you
have something no i i'll say it after uh
we watched so let's let's finish what he
says about these pro-lifers
and the proof
of the [ __ ] that that is the
dismount there that might be something
christ would do and really i mean it
shouldn't be surprising that they're
[ __ ] hypocrites
not only is this a classic
um uh comedy routine from george garland
but this is something way beyond just
comedy this is way beyond something just
to make you laugh um george carlin had a
way of doing comedy and i think there's
a new documentary which i can't wait for
it to come out on hbo yeah yeah hbo max
i believe it's the 20th of this month
and i can't wait to watch this um i'm a
george garland fan have been for a long
time i re-watch his specials
and george had a way of not just making
you laugh but the purpose was to make
you think
and not think about the issue but think
about the way you
think about the issue i think that's
important i think sometimes we're
missing that
in our national discourse don't you no
completely and and i think to the point
that you're making about george carlin
is like it's not only he had a way of
deli like you know
yelling and getting to the point and
hitting the punch line it's also
incredibly cathartic for people i mean
i'm not going to say george carlin is a
you know is a soothsayer or or like
someone who can you know predict the
future
but there was a lot of wisdom
and prediction in the jokes that he said
he wasn't just telling it you know just
you know a dick joke here and a dick
joke there he's telling you truths
and making you laugh and think and
question about it right he's giving you
this cathartic release like holy [ __ ]
this is like it's not that bad
but where he sees it going right like
that's what his gift was that's what he
was really great at is that he was able
to look
at this situation and and observe it and
say
it's [ __ ] up now
and if we don't fix it like we can laugh
and joke all we want but it's going to
get really [ __ ] up later down the line
and here we are right like you know he
passed away in what 2008 right i think
it's been 14 years since george
garland's and so you you look at this
point you know 14 years later and it's
like holy [ __ ] man this guy was on the
[ __ ]
he was right on it the whole especially
he got it all right this special was
shot back in 1996 and george carlin had
been making abortion
um he had abortion bits long before this
uh not quite as long as a dietary uh for
this um but a lot of the points that he
made against organized religion you know
pressing the religion upon us uh he has
a lot of bits about that as well um but
i think i think the point is is that we
all should think and again to all you
second amendment you know if you're hate
watching me out there and you love the
second amendment and you you yell and
scream about elon musk having your first
freedom of speech and all this [ __ ]
protect your v forget those amendments
right forget that [ __ ] these people do
not want you to have the freedom of
speech even though you think oh i'm one
of them i'm one of them i'm one of them
i'm one of the fascist
they're they're the people who are in
charge
are going to suppress and censor and
take away your freedom of speech the
only speech you will have is to praise
them that is it you will not have the
right to own guns unless they allow you
to carry one unless they can trust you
that you won't turn it on them a
tyrannical a tyrannical government right
they're only going to give you so much
they're only going to give you the idea
that you have power that's right you
know for the same reason it's like oh
you could yeah well-formed militia great
good luck until we [ __ ] take that
[ __ ] away right and then you're like oh
well what happened i thought we were we
were besties i thought we were friends
no no no no we're not besties we're not
friends because at the end of the day
the same people like you said are like
yeah [ __ ] it let's take away the rights
we're [ __ ] fascists ah you know these
people are the same people that believe
that they're capitalists that work for
big corporations and it's like no my guy
you're just an employee you're a cog and
a big [ __ ] machine okay
so if you come at the end of the day and
say i'm i'm ah i'm a fascist i'm taking
you know whether they say it out loud or
not but i'm taking the rights because
these people don't deserve them it's
like oh buddy my guy wait until they
take your [ __ ] away right right you're
really [ __ ] you are just a pawn you
are just a piece in this whole [ __ ]
game right they're gonna they're gonna
make you think that it's a good thing
that you got your rights taken away
that's what they're gonna make you think
about yeah well i mean it's a good thing
that we're that we're giving up our guns
it's a good thing because you know and
we we definitely need to not have speech
against the dictator and the almighty
authoritarian right donald trump it's a
good thing
when it gets to the point that you you
look around and you go
wait
wait wait wait wait wait
we we don't have our guns anymore we
don't have these frights anymore that
you were like oh only those people
should have those rights taken away when
you look around and you realize that
you're just like everybody [ __ ] else
in this situation
it's too [ __ ] late that's right
they're coming for you uh speaking of
dumb [ __ ] who don't understand rights
and what [ __ ] is this is a very um and
everyone i got this on my timeline you
should share this around um this just
shows how [ __ ] unserious these people
are about about the partial birth
abortion which is a [ __ ] lie by the
way don't let anyone out there be
tweeting at you be talking to you about
partial birth abortion that's a [ __ ]
lie it's a [ __ ] there is no parts of
burst abortions all the pictures they
show of doctors taking babies out before
that's all [ __ ] that is complete
utter 100
[ __ ] they do not do partial birth
abortions that's a made-up term that's a
made-up thing just like crt and math
books down in florida it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's made up so they can take
your rights away but speaking of dumb
bucks who don't even understand don't
even understand simple science or not
even willing to even just just just a
little bit
just a little bit do a little bit of
research on science before they form
their fascist opinions here's charlie
kirk who is vehemently opposed to
women's rights i mean he [ __ ] hates
women he [ __ ] hates women and listen
um
to ben i think his name's ben how do you
say his last name gl glebe
i think i think it's sleep yeah ben
glebe he's a host of a couple different
uh talk shows but he says he's a
comedian i think he does a stand-up too
but he was on several years ago he was
on charlie kirk's debate night and they
were there to debate abortion and you
can see the heading here says charlie
kirk schooled on abortion in 15 seconds
and it's the truth you got to watch this
video we'll watch it a couple times here
because it's so short but watch how ben
absolutely destroys charlie kirk here
because charlie kirk is not willing not
willing to do a little bit of background
to figure out what the [ __ ] the lies he
is telling watch this
do you truly in your heart of hearts
truly believe that this is a human being
this without a doubt without a doubt yes
this is a dolphin fetus
without a doubt a dolphin fetus is a
human being this is a human being
but
quite differently
you just confirmed that
in life you confuse dolphins for human
babies often so when you go to see world
and you're like someone's got human
babies
so i'm going to play it again here
though but for all those listening what
happens is to describe the video here
ben and charlie are sitting down to have
a debate and and charlie's got his
notebook full of women there i guess i
don't know what it is uh is it is that
related to the binder full of women well
that might be as romney yeah it might be
as binderful women but uh ben pulls out
a picture and it's a picture of a of a
of a fetus um and it appears to be a
fetus a mammal fetus which it is um and
charlie definitely buys the argument
almost immediately which ben knew he
would ben knew without a doubt charlie
kirk without any questioning
would not question
his instincts to absolutely denigrate
women
by telling them what is in their body
right that's what he's doing is he's
denigrating women by telling women what
the [ __ ] is in their body he can't have
one of these things in his body he can't
have a [ __ ] abortion what state does
he have about this fetus being a dolphin
or a human or whatnot ben knows this ben
knows immediately charlie kirk is gonna
take the bait
and he does
let's listen to it one more time when he
holds up the picture of the fetus listen
to what charlie kirk says and i mean it
is instantaneous the position that he
takes to presume that he knows what is
inside a woman's body so you truly in
your heart of hearts
truly believe that this is a human being
this without a doubt without a doubt yes
this is a dolphin fetus
it doesn't stop being funny really
it's so good because he goes with
complete confidence oh yes like almost
as confident susan collins believing
that gorsuch and kavanaugh wouldn't
overturn roe versus wade that's right
that's right and and it's a beautiful
it's a beautiful piece of art um that
should live on the internet forever and
ever and ever and thank you ben uh if
you're out there um for giving us that
that that piece of content forever and
ever and ever of of the absolute lunacy
that a man like charlie kirk
would presume to know what the [ __ ] is
in a woman's body what in the [ __ ] do
you know about a goddamn woman's body
what do you probably as much as ben
shapiro or nick fuentes know about
pleasuring a woman right well nick
fuentes to get the nazi that we played
earlier who thinks women should get a
thousand years in prison folks he has
admitted on on film that he's never even
been with a woman yeah that's not my
choice either okay well no why can you
tell well i mean like again george
carlin nailed it on the head the people
that are so so [ __ ] up in arms and
want to make sure that abortion is
illegal are the same people that nobody
would want to ever you would not want to
[ __ ] these people you would not want to
[ __ ] these people
speaking of speaking of men presuming
[ __ ] about women and it is kind of funny
how these these in-cell men who can't
get people to [ __ ] them want to want to
legislate women's bodies but they don't
want to legislate man's bodies right i
mean gabe
if if there was a bill somewhere today
in the united states and it went to the
supreme court where there was uh
mandatory vasectomies holy [ __ ] i mean
first off i would sign up right well i i
just
if i could cut out yeah all the other
problems that could happen right in
terms of like accidental pregnancy or or
just the cost of you know now most
states gave most states most states i
believe will not let you get a vasectomy
unless unless you have children see see
that's so messed up well but but but
here's the thing here's the thing
is that there are there are over 400
bills that are legislating
women's bodies do you know how many
bills there are out there legislating
man's bodies
not a goddamn one zero and irish girl
here points it out in her video uh i i
believe this was either last night or
this morning this is [ __ ] fantastic
she channels the [ __ ] i'm just
completely i i feel like i have found
have found my sister from another mother
here
when she when she does her video here
i've always felt that way about her
videos because she does not give a
single [ __ ] not a single [ __ ] to give
when it comes to her language and how
she and how she frames up these
arguments let's listen to what she has
to say oh hello
did you know that every two minutes a
child is removed from their home and
placed into the foster care system did
you know that there are over 400 000
children in foster care did you know
some states allow agencies to ban gay
couples from fostering or adopting a
child did you know that one in seven
children are food insecure and that
there are over
2.5 million homeless children in this
country
tick tock [ __ ] it's not
equality if there are over 400 proposed
bills trying to regulate my body versus
zero to regulate a man's a woman's right
to choose is exactly that her right
without the asterisk it is time to abort
the republican party unless you have a
vagina stop telling me what to do with
god damn right go [ __ ] yourself
republicans
go [ __ ] yourself
abortion is health care
and none of your business
god
damn i'm not wrong god damn
whoo
here's the thing as a man i'm not going
to tell a woman what to do right that's
her body just like you know a woman
didn't tell anyone else what to do with
their body but like in this situation
again
their body their choice right you want a
[ __ ] about masks and what i can wear
and what i can't wear in the government
tyrant you know tyrannical government
[ __ ] and all this [ __ ]
at the end of the day it's my body and i
do what i want to so i'm not going to
tell a woman i can tell my girlfriend
what you can do with her body i'm not
going to tell my mother what you can do
with her body i'm not going to tell
anyone else what they can do with their
body because you know what it's their
[ __ ] thing it's they are their own
[ __ ] they deal with it
they've been able to uh raise themselves
take care of themselves feed themselves
shelter themselves
they should be able to have the decision
of what they want to do with their own
[ __ ] body and if that's you know what
i don't feel like i should have a child
right now
or i can't or there's some medical
situation i need to actually have an
abortion a safe abortion
then that's that's that is no way in any
way a man's or anyone else's right to
say otherwise it is only that woman and
only hers
and i'll tell you what if if men if men
could have abortions oh my god they
would be in the streets right now and
really though we wouldn't be talking
about this really yeah yeah
i mean they talked about they joke about
guns right and they're like oh if we if
we made a ban on a you know an abortion
ban on guns
right you would you would find men
running in the street in the nra being
up in arms and storming the supreme
court like easily well guns have more
rights than women now yeah according to
alito states rights and guns and all
those bulls
okay so you brought up you brought up
the fact that the maskers you know these
anti-maskers my body the anti-vaxxers my
body my choice uh walter did an
interview here at a trump rally i'm glad
you brought this up did you act it's
almost like you knew i was gonna segue
into this or something
um here is here's a video that walter a
friend of our show walter masterson put
out that he partnered with midas dutch
our partner and patriot takes here at a
trump rally and he's interviewing
anti-vaxxer and then he asked him he
asked him why he's an anti-vascular and
then he asked him you know about the my
body your choice or my body my choice
actually they do believe it's my body
our choice to do over your body but
let's listen they don't give trump the
credit for getting the vaccine out there
and rushing it through the market
getting it in there and just like
greasing the skids right correct yeah
are you getting vaccinated no
i have asthma
i'm at i'm
at risk course no you're not no you're
not
but with that being said
my constitutional freedom listen to this
don't end where your political beliefs
start okay listen to what he said there
this is very important it's my body my
choice listen to what he says about his
constitutional rights my body it's my
choice it's your body your choice but
with that being said
my constitutional freedoms
don't end where your
political beliefs start so he believes
he believes that his body his choice and
your your political beliefs do not
infringe on his bodily autonomy is what
he's saying i mean you know
him right him specifically
he has a white man right uh mj thank you
for the uh super chat she said stay
pissed folks
six months to change hearts and minds uh
mj we are going to start today today
we're starting today but let's finish
what this guy says
what walter asked him about next about
bodily autonomy and other people's
bodily time let's let's see what this
guy actually believes about bodily
autonomy period end of story what are
you gonna do about this whole abortion
thing
it needs to be abolished
abortion needs to be abolished yes they
don't
again go back to the old george garland
when you say
isn't it kind of [ __ ] funny that
these these anti-abortion
uh pro-life [ __ ] are people you
wouldn't want to [ __ ] in the first place
i mean yeah these are not the people you
want to [ __ ] or procreate with right and
they're people that really hang around
hang around yeah totally in the same
vicinity really it's like when you when
you are with others you want diverse
diverse opinions and experiences because
you want to better yourself you want to
expand your knowledge you want to you
want to basically not uh atrophy in
different ways
and i have to say that in many ways like
that guy who's a [ __ ] idiot uh who
runs right into the point and then runs
right through it
right i feel like having a conversation
with them is well i know from experience
is one constant [ __ ] migraine but
also is one where
you would just
get [ __ ] dumber by being around them
right like you adapt to your
surroundings
oh my god being being in a room with
that person more than an hour i feel
like i would want to bash my head
through the [ __ ] wall
because you're like no you don't get it
and it's like no you don't [ __ ] get
it right right well you know uh satire
is dead
um and that that may just prove it right
there that that satires did
oh thank you for joining us today i want
to remind everyone um that we will not
we're not going to stop talking about
this issue and this is going to be a a
continuing uh theme here and we're gonna
bring on more and more people um to talk
about this issue um and hopefully
uh those voices can be amplified so do
us a favor follow us on facebook the
minus facebook page we broadcast there
so follow us there but also if you're on
facebook go over to the youtube channel
subscribe to the youtube channel because
you can find us every single weekday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
right here on youtube if you're on
facebook right up there at the post
there's the uh the little link there to
go to our youtube page
uh subscribe there we again we are on
every single weekday monday through
friday nine eastern 11 central
excuse me noon
[Music]
noon 12 eastern what do you think jesus
christ this is um i mean west coast is
the best coast baby yes i i've been
super pissed today um i'm i'm kind of my
head is still raging i'm still in a fire
here so folks please please come
subscribe to the youtube channel our
twitch or twitter follow us at
tonymichaelspod
on twitter you can find our broadcast
there or you can go do the bonehead of
the week poll that'll come out on
thursday you know we do that every
single thursday i want to point out
something um that mj just gave us a
super sticker but she also said that she
can't have a cuss word in the in the
super sticker i guess um so everyone
everyone beware that youtube is
censoring
youtube is centering here tech baby she
said super chat won't let me uh use cuss
words sons of [ __ ]
tons of [ __ ] but just just give it an
asterisk or something yeah and then
we'll say that
ck
and well she also says you're welcome
folks if you can there's a 99 cent
sticker don't forget if you're on
youtube that is one thing you can do is
participate in the super chat we always
appreciate
uh any support you give rather you go
download the episode on apple spotify
google all your directories we're having
record-breaking downloads gabe over
there yeah more and more people are
coming to download i think they love our
beautiful voices
we have record-breaking views so they
apparently
so fingers crossed just keeps going yeah
i don't i don't know if they think i'm
good looking or you're good looking or
if it's just like a combination but um
they aren't there maybe maybe like maybe
like jd mandel right we could maybe
people think that we are the same like
tony tony sanchez
[Laughter]
god damn
so before we leave there is one more
video um that i want to play for midas
dutch speaking that we're a minus touch
partner um i wanted to play it it's only
a couple minutes long here before we
leave but i do want to play it um
this is called despicable gop and it is
the people who are trying to take your
rights away and might just touch nail
right on the head just like they did
with the handmade cell watch this video
warning
the following are real uncensored
statements from republicans about rape
and reproductive rights
viewer discretion is advised
rape is kind of like the weather if it's
inevitable relax and enjoy it clayton
williams
if it's a legitimate rape the female
body has ways to try and shut that whole
thing down
todd aiken
rape victims should make the best of a
bad situation accept what god is giving
to you rick santorum
even when life begins in a horrible
situation
that it is something
god intended to happen richard murdoch
in the emergency room they have what's
called rape kits where a woman can get
cleaned out
jodie laubenberg
if not for rape and incest
would there be any population left
she was dressed like a 21 year old
prostitute
students should show up in proper attire
kathleen pasado said this about an 11
year old girl gang raped in texas by 18
men
if a woman has the right to an abortion
why shouldn't a man be able to use his
superior strength to force himself on a
woman at least the rapist pursuit of
sexual freedom doesn't in most cases
result in anyone's death
lawrence lachman
what is the value of that life and is it
subordinate to the value of its host
body
jose oliva
this is the republican party
never forget
wrote them
out
they're not hosts women are not hosts
they're not host bodies women are not
toys women aren't vessels that's right
that's right they are [ __ ] human
beings they have human rights in this
country and by god are you ready to
fight because i'm ready to [ __ ] oh
yeah [ __ ] you i am ready to go on that
hill that they want to die on and that
that fat those fascist [ __ ]
want to die on i am ready to fight and
fight and use the ballot as our weapon
and take back our democracy from these
stupid [ __ ] fascists it is enough is
enough of this nin coop poop nazi [ __ ]
it's time that we show them what
democracy is now is the time not
tomorrow not next week not after the
midterms to see what happens now today
right now this hour we've got
[ __ ] months
so put out the tweets and get on your
feet and get in the streets i don't know
we'll come up with some kind of
good rhyme there uh
thank you for joining us here on the
tony michaels podcast tomorrow again
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific so
you get it right there youtube twitter
and twitch go follow us
over there and subscribe to youtube just
type in the tony michaels podcast or if
you're on facebook click the link at the
top of the post there you'll come over
and subscribe
because we are on the midas touch
facebook page
and you know gabe until tomorrow really
i mean tomorrow's gonna be an important
day as well to fight for our democracy
just like today was and the day after
that and the day after that and the day
after that and we will be here
every single weekday live for two hours
monday through friday to fight for our
democracy and give you our messaging
stay tuned and surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking